pushing off on Pachulia Leonard fires
from the corner and Leonard goes down
again and he's in pain again in front of
the Spurs bench will summoning the long
side athletic trainer for the Spurs
checking out in the crowd reacting to
the replay of that call on the big
screen and let her gingerly getting up
again that's that's what they call all
the time when you get your feet into the
landing space of the shooter
[Applause]
an ankle taking a pounding here in the
third quarter one that was already saw
[Applause]
and how much you turning him now is
gonna shoot the free throws because if
he couldn't then he wouldn't be able to
return to the game the only way you can
do that on an injury is if it's a
flagrant two foul and you see Simmons
coming back into this ball game quote
for qilin and I think the mindset is
pretty much like the mindset of Game six
if we cannot beat the Warriors up 20
something with almost eight minutes to
go in the third without trial in it and
how good are we real so you want to make
sure he's healthy and whole well he's 11
for 11 from the free-throw line 26
points and then green fouls to get
Leonard out of the game again he had to
shoot the free throws to stay in it
Casey wants to return but he's gonna
over to the bench I don't like that foul
by Danny Green I think you need to suck
if you're gonna take a foul what a guy
who's not gonna play in on the free
throw so that when you throw it in you
don't have one of your better players
taking an unnecessary foul and that's
his third foul there you see seven again
Leonard go curry fakes curry drives
kicks it out Pachulia open baseline
jumper is Josh up patchouli with his
third field goal and you think about
fitting in Leonard go curry fakes curry
drives kicks it out Pachulia open
baseline jumper Josh up patchouli with
his third field goal on the pole curry
pulls back rebound Durant but trulia
kept it alive and Durant on the follow
it's a 12-point game Thompson off the
dribble drives and this is ball tipped
out to Durant back to Thompson for three
Ginobli tried to draw the foul
curry a two-pointer puts it in 16
straight points timeout San Antonio the
Warriors taking out a rhythm hurry with
the steal ahead to Durant Durant drives
and flushes
for the third quarter Aldrich connects
and that ends in 1801 see anybody that
Houston had John same arose back in the
games and obly drives and finishes
Ginobili and green two fantastic second
round picks going at each other curry
foul line jumper 33 for curry
shot clock down to eight crossover drive
layup good Manu Ginobili back-to-back
buckets don't tell me you're about
winning show it to me great off the
dribble move there against the small
slower and reporter Anderson grabs it I
head to Murray Murray releases Durant
and pursuit lamp it's good and the foul
and that's four fouls on Durant
right now Simmons corner to Anderson and
to sit off the dribble a little floater
and Anderson off the bench with his
first field goal
shot clock down to eight curry finds
Pachulia but Julia finds the rim banks
at home
don't foul again Marie the drive flips
it up shot won't go
anna-san cuts it in at the buzzer Spurs
did so many role players throughout
these playoffs King playing key roles
for their team then that 18o run Ian
Clark has come on Murray gets it out to
Simmons and Simmons calmly six in green
throws it away
Thompson Ian Clark three-pointer cuts it
in but can't come up with a steal
Aldridge foul and one Thompson coming to
help all the pass deflected break TT
from Golden State Clark slices inside
back up pop Durant for three
Durant drives inside and finishes
timeout San Antonio it's a four-point
game
awful defense by colonists and a great
job by Sean limits in grabbing Ginobli
not allowing him to get in front rolled
man who hot from the third quarter
Aldridge goes inside reverse left ball
tipped up and in by Murray and he
rewards his coaches confidence
Durant contested three Kevin Durant from
downtown he's got 30 Ginobili gets
inside shots good all the magic of Manu
Ginobili is to ask him to guard Kevin
Durant is so difficult there at the
crossover the pull up the jumper skirt
Ginobli now on draymond Green back to
Livingston throws it down it's cut to
one Murray the cross over the floor
Haho the jumping st. Marie will a
gorgeous move good good defense by
Murray on the other in offense tree does
a good job putting his head down to
break people down off the dribble
Livingston looking to post-up Murray
backs in shock rolls around it's cut had
the foul you see the work done by Murray
but we've seen this time and time again
Shaun Livingston taking advantage of his
size that's not a foul
Durant lost it got it back in late today
warriors lead
now to make plays and be a grunt curry
comes off the screen fires a three
dream on bringing the follow is good
Vantage of the size being defended by
Simmons can't keep them off the board
boosting up as hard block from Durant
Aldridge gets it back Albert puts it up
and gets the roll
LaMarcus Aldridge stays with the play of
the Spurs back up by one gets free fakes
fires three-pointers won't go rebound
curry cross-court to Durant Durant with
a three pointer ball tipped again picked
up by curry curry for three
[Applause]
klay Thompson off the dribble pass
inside the green plays it is warriors
back up and the foul being turned
[Music]
Ginobli the drive Ginobli sucks it curry
pulls back holders picks him up curry on
the drive throws it up shocks bounces
around and drops road
[Applause]